hello hello everyone and welcome to
another live stream in which we're going
to solve project Euler challenges using
javascript for those of you who didn't
join the first live stream we had I
think two weeks ago we solve the first
four problems using the free code camp
platform and in this dream we're going
to solve a couple more we'll see how it
goes and how many we can solve if you
join the live stream I can see close to
100 people being like say hi in the chat
and yeah keep in mind that yeah I didn't
prepare for this problem so well I don't
have the solution I looked over to see
how it looks and well how it works how
it should work like a main idea but I
didn't solve them and that's because I
want to show you how how you can even
fail when you start doing something you
start coding on something and that's
perfectly normal so yeah we're going to
try and solve this on the first go and
see how it goes for those of you who
don't know me my name is Larry Popp I'm
a developer from Romania I have a
YouTube channel where you can find me
live coding almost daily and I also
upload different videos or you can
follow me on Twitter if you want alright
I see Quincy hello Quincy get so yeah I
think you can hear me let me know in the
chat and we can start with the problem
number five the smallest multiple
let's see what it requires smallest
multiple 2520 is the smallest number
that can be divided by each of the
numbers from 1 to 10 without any
reminder what is the smallest positive
number that is evenly divisible by all
of the numbers from 1 to n all right so
we're having to deal with the divisible
numbers
okay
yeah also as Quincy met Christmas and
the chat for now is for members only if
you want to enjoy the chat I haven't be
able to chat with me and engage consider
becoming a member you also support this
awesome
platform and help other developers learn
how to code for free
alright so let's see we need to figure
out how well probably this one of the
problems I wanted to solve today is the
hardest and that's because well we could
go so we need to get all the numbers
from one to add and then we need to find
the smallest number which can be divided
by each of these numbers right now this
could be trickier we could just start
and multiply 1 + 1 with 2 + 3 + 4 up to
n but then we'll get a very high number
and that's not the smallest number
possible I know that there is a function
but I knew about it but I kind of forgot
in which you could check for you could
have two numbers and check which is the
lowest column multiplier let's let's go
the latency lowest common divisor
ya think ya LCD I think for not
denominator let's see
to do to do
or so this could be one approach to use
this function although it can see it now
or we can go the brute-force and start
with a number well actually let's do
that we're going to have one number to
start with and we're going to increase
this number and check for every number
if it's divisible by all the numbers
from 1 to n and I guess the starting
number could be n hey kattiline welcome
to the live stream how are you okay and
now we kind of need another function to
check Thank You kattiline to check if
the number we're going to give it is
divisible by all the numbers so let's
write check the Visser's and we'll get
the number and the desserts oh this is
kind of interesting it as well these
divisors will be also number we're going
to loop or alright let's go with this
and then we can slowly improve the
function so here we're going to go from
let I be dessert well it should be I 1
then it will go less than pickles to the
number the divisor Haitian thank you for
the super chat well thank you on behalf
of Rico camp obviously alright so let's
see here I don't like the names here so
maybe number two check and number all
right so let's do this and here we can
check if kattiline thank you for the
super chat ok so if our number well i
modulus number two check
[Music]
so if this is different than zero so
that means it's not divisible then we
want return false right so think about
this we're going to start with a number
which will be the biggest number here
well yeah okay let's let's Candide
itself we're going to take for example a
let's write examples here will be easier
to explain so we have the numbers from 1
to 10 right and we need to find lowest
well the smallest multiply for
but well the smallest number that can be
divided by all these numbers right which
we know that is 2520 and what time we're
going to do here is we're going to start
with them start with 10 and then we're
slowing slowly going to go up 10 11 12
13 14 and we're going to check all of
these numbers if they are divisible by
all the numbers from 1 to 10
hopefully that makes sense let me know
it'll chat if it does or if it does it
all right so that's what we're going to
do here we're going to have a while look
not sorry for the wire loop should be
the best way to go we might get an
infinite loop but well let's let's try
for now yeah say they say that an
infinite loop but actually we could have
a boolean found be false and while not
found
we can Oh also we need to work we're
going to use a start so while not found
we're going to check the results we're
going to pax the number two chapel which
will be the start or what them start
again not a good name
so that's right number to check alright
so we're going to check the number to
check and we're going to pass in the app
which will be our number then here
infinite loop hype if this returns true
then we want to well found be true so
we're setting found to be true well
again it says that we have an infinite
loop like don't know if this is the best
approach that well let's see how it is
as a set this is proud of the hardness
of the ones forget to do today so let's
see again we have the number to check
starting with the highest one all right
then we're going to pass in the number
to check oh and here we wanted the
number to check plus plus right we want
to increase the number and at the end
we're going to return this
okay so we're capping the number we're
checking for divisors
if it's divisible by all of these
numbers well here we need to return true
if it doesn't find a number which is not
visible then should be true
okay and
yet this should probably work although
let's check
it might run my timeout yeah so
something is not okay
yes
yes if you're in the live chat if you
have an 80 feel free to suggest okay
let's think again
well this check divisor work so
we have I 1 I less the number I plus
plus okay so we get the numbers from 1
to 10 for example if we have the number
10 okay well you know what
[Music]
let me see so we need to check all the
numbers okay number to check
oh my bass the number to check has to be
divisible by I right yeah kinda messed
it up there
okay let's also cancel that vlog Ness to
see what we get okay number two check 30
which is yet so we're passing 20 we need
to check out numbers from 1 to 20 all
right and here we're saving it to the
number to check now let's see if the
while look while loop works
okay so we get this number
which is not what we wanted
what is that isn't it
check modulus I do different and Sarah
so it's not
okay what we get for five
60 we get 61 alright good good good good
good so we're kind of closer here we get
61 because we increment here once again
so we kind of want to do it here
all right yet so now we know at least
one test will work if we don't have well
that's nice I didn't expect this to be
honest
so apparently all of them work now yes
this is the life of a programmer it
works and you don't always know why but
yeah you have a nice goal there
kattiline okay so could we improve this
should we try to improve this or we
should just leave it yeah so we're kind
of checking all the numbers which is not
powers oh yeah I think that number to
check which we did there good thing
number to check should be here although
now if we have a number like 2
save for and that's not good right
because we're starting with this number
but then we increment in the wire loop
so I kind of want to do n minus so one
okay so now we get to sorry so yeah what
about three three won't work for for for
we should get let's see not six not
eight probably twelve oh look at that
yeah stuff so yeah this works now my
trophy all right so let's run this let's
submit and go to the next one which
hopefully will be easier we did it the
brute force way which is not well always
the best solution but if you don't have
another solution it should work
all right problem six sum square
difference the sum of the squares of the
first ten natural number is three
hundred and eighty five the square of
the sum of the first 10 utter number is
three thousand twenty-five hence the
difference between the sum of the
squares of the first ten at your number
and the seventh and the square of the
sum is that number all right find the
difference between the sum of the
squares for the first and natural
numbers and the sum of and the square of
the sum that's interesting there yet so
yeah basically again we need to take all
the numbers from one to ten or well one
to n we need to add them up and then
raise them to the power of two or we
need to raise them individual to the
power of two and then add them up and
the result of these two well we need to
subtract so yeah this shouldn't be that
hard now
okay let me see
I could oh yeah that's better
so let's create two functions one will
create the square of the sum and when we
create the sum of the squares so
function square square of sums sum K and
function sum of squares okay get and
both of them receive and
we could create an array and use map and
the reducer yeah I'm kind of complicated
over complicated now let me also add
console clock here so we can see what we
get
all right so we need the sum of the so
the square of the sum minus the sum of
the squares let's go hear some once more
so square of some square of sum of n
minus sum of squares of that
alright not a number yet now here well
for one we need left I equals zero
well I equals 1 I less than equals and I
plus plus and square of some yeah we're
going to have a sum which will be 0 and
then sound plus equals I so we're
getting all the numbers there and then
we're returning some for now in this
square of sum so we can do
either met that power some until let me
return here one so we can see something
in the console or we can do I think this
is a newer thing never used well it
didn't really use it we can do this
which is pretty much the same thing but
yeah this is more obvious that we're
raising the Sam ^ - good now for the
next one well we're having pretty much
the same thing but instead of adding so
let's remember the sum instead of adding
I here we're going to add map that POW i
^ - so we're squaring the numbers and
yeah this should yeah it looks like it
works for 100 this should work it's
brute force I'm not sure if you can do
it
other way
I know there is a formula for adding the
numbers I've learned that in high school
song time for adding the numbers from 1
to N it was something like let's see if
I remember so n times n plus 1 divided
by 2 so this should be the total and
here we can do whoa wait wait wait not
here this will work here because we're
having the sum
yeah oh not n times n plus one like this
see so this works basically I remember
that for the numbers from 1 to 10 it was
like 55 so yeah this is the formula and
well we don't have to do the loop which
is good we saved some time here we can
also put this
here well let's leave it there we can
use cops because we're not reeling yet
now about days let's search a square sum
of square formula sum of squares formula
why not let's learn something new today
k n n plus 1 and 2 n plus 1/6 all right
thank you google so this is the formula
let's use this so we kind of don't have
taste here and this will be two times
and all right let's return this
and here this
and is not oh oh sorry so and it's not
the function we need to multiply there
and here also alright so yeah this is I
think this is now the more cleaner way
it should say I was doing this we're
using formulas instead of looping over
which is pretty good it's way way faster
this way because we're just multiplying
instead of looping because if we had a
big big big number
well then would have some problems there
all right
so yeah let's submit this and go to the
next one
seven ten thousand one 10,000 first
Prime I think by listing the first six
prime numbers 2 3 5 7 11 and 13 we can
see that the sixth prime is 13 again
what is the nth prime nice
prime numbers
[Music]
okay let's see so first what we could do
again the brute force method
and go over all the numbers from 1 to X
well this case is M but we want the end
pride we don't want to go up to end like
we had before so we can start again and
check all the primes get the primes and
store them inside an array and when we
get to an array of length of n we're
going to output the last one
this is the first idea I had let's see
if that works although this is again the
brute force but maybe we could improve
it afterwards now let's see so we're
going to need left number which will
start from let's so two is the first
prime number good
and let Prime's will be an array and I'm
going to put a number inside because
while two is already a prime all right
while this could be a Const because
we're pushing to it okay
let's see and here what we can already
do Prime's
that pop because pop sounds nice and
well it will return the last one and
this is what we want what's the end
prime okay and we can do a while loop
while Prime's that length is less than n
so while we don't have the primes we
want to well push to the primes so
Prime's that push on the next prime
number
mm-hmm okay let's think here
Oh
we get Prime so we could loop
and find primes
mmm
let's do that so we're going to well we
have the number there right the starting
number
and here we can do a check of it if it's
a prime if is prime the number then we
want to push the primes array okay I
guess then we can remove it from here
because automatic it automatically two
will be added at the end here we're
going to do number plus plus
and we kind of just need a prime is
prime functional so how do we check if
the number is prime well a function
yeah there is a thing I'm I'm thinking
now we could do to improve because only
2 is 2 is the only prime number which is
an even number all the rest are odd
numbers yeah
English samples so we killed two numbers
plus equal to
just so we can save half after loops
loops count so let's do that we're going
to push to here and we're going to start
from three so now we don't check for all
the numbers we just check for the odd
ones okay good so that's an improvement
it will also probably not work for well
it will probably timeout you know it
depends on how long it will take yet so
is prime let's write another function
which you're taking a number and it will
return if it's pride so return through
here by default we're going to assume
it's prime and here we're going to do a
check so we need to start
from two
let's go up to the number I plus plus
and here we want to check
mm-hm so let's see we're going to start
with three it will check the division so
if number modulus I will be 0 then
return false
because the number one number is prime
if only is divisible by 1 and itself
right so we don't want to go up to the
number very well inclusive the number
okay and we check so we go here and we
check is it divisible by 2 with 0
reminder if it is then well it's not a
prime then we go up one more if it's
divisible by 3 and so on and so forth
okay we again have a potential infinite
loop
but this should work now so we're
checking if it's a prime if it is well
we push it here in the primes array and
when the primes rate length is equal to
n we we get the end right let's see what
we get
let me console that love this okay so
for that we get that number which is not
correct
let's see what we have in the primes
array
okay so two three five seven eleven
thirteen seventeen okay this looks it
looks like we have the prime numbers
well let me use it for six
kay
so if you do pop here what happened we
have 30
which is good let's see for 10 we get 29
the last yes for 100 we get 541
thousand
let's dip up here again
okay
so somewhere around there it fails let's
learn the test and see what we get
now that's weird
why did you get that
you know what it did it
let's see again for 2001 we should get
that number but we get this that's
interesting
might be something here
yeah so it kind of stops in a in this
terminal or whatever it is but it works
murder while we're running the test okay
[Music]
there are a couple of things well a
couple I have one idea which we could
improve you can see here that we're also
going again over all the numbers which
is not a key we also need to do
something like we did here
to skip well at least we could to skip
every two numbers so we could do here if
number modules 2 is 0 then return false
this is for the base condition that 2
and then here we could start with 3 and
[Music]
oh wait
no no I'm wrong here so yeah we need to
go over our lumbers because we could get
a number and CV
happen here
we won't check for even numbers right so
there's no way in trying to
to check with another even number okay
so yeah that should work well let's see
so this is what I wanted to save more
more loops here let's this
okay
yeah although it took more time which is
odd
but at least here you can see here we
now got the number so it's it's faster
okay and I think we also don't need to
go up to the number we can go up to the
square root we did it the last time
but I forgot again so let's see ya know
again up to the square root
yeah so that works also we don't go up
to the number but up to the square root
so we save even more more loops all
right so I think that's it for this one
let's go to the next one
can we stay
we have 1% complete
that's my later place okay problem eight
largest product in a series the four
adjacent digits in the 1000 digits
number that we have the greatest product
are nine times nine times eight times
nine
large production series okay so we have
this big number and we need to find the
and adjacent digits in the 1000 digits
number that have the greatest product
what is the value of this product
all right so yeah we're getting a number
and we need to find a number
when
to find a number which is n digits and
it digits is the highest product Thank
You Quincey I think for supporting the
organization yeah she'd done it well I
am a member on YouTube so see I think I
have
they had the emoji but I don't have it I
don't see no never works okay so what we
need to do we have this array which they
provided for us thank you
which is good because it's already an
array so we can work with the numbers
and if we have a number of lengths
well if then and here is for window
check this for store the product then
check this for check the product is
bigger than the previous product and so
on and so forth up to
Yeah right
okay we need to get those ohms if we
have five numbers we need to check like
five numbers every times so we can do
that using well we again need to go over
all these numbers right so all these
numbers and get the pair of four five or
six numbers or how many they are we can
do that using the slice method we can
start from the index and get
yes the slice or the splice method but
the splice will change this array so let
me first move this from here I'm going
to create it here comes tiles and digits
okay so we have we have a room here next
up we want to create a loop which will
go over basically all these digits right
don't worry kattiline I know it's a joke
okay so it goes over all the digits it
will get the pair's and check the next
one and so on and so forth so well
what's the data for let is 0 I less than
and for now but we're going to change
this and I plus plus get and here take
the pair it's not a pair how they call
ends multiple take the series sirree
ever and check the product here we're
going to store the maximum product so
max product will be the lowest number
possible so yeah let's put 0 we're going
to check if
[Music]
series product
is great
than Max product then we want to do max
product be equal to serious product okay
this is the function we are going to
create okay good now because we're
calling it twice well let's move it out
in a variable so comest product will be
series product and here we're going to
test in an array with all the numbers we
want
okay get and at the end we're going to
return the max product let's console.log
it again all right now the only thing
it's left oh we are left to do is to
create this array so we want to get n
numbers at a time so starting with the
index we can do that by let's see so
have this array let's write it here
array will be this
that's slice slice needs the index on
which you want to start so it will be I
and the second index the second argument
will be our parameter will be
you want to end but not inclusive so we
want to do i+ n so let's see if we start
this will be zero we if we do I plus and
which is five we're going to up to five
but not inclusive so we want we
basically want to get all these right
seven three one six seven and slice will
give us this four because it goes up to
so we can do I plus and plus one and now
it will take all the five in the next
loop it will start from this one and
take all the five and then this one is
so on and so forth we're going to pass
this to our cities product yeah
let's write it here like another
function but then afterwards we'd like
to write it in line so function series
product will get an array and we want to
do the product of all the numbers we can
do that using reduce so hooray that
reduce which gets an accumulator we're
going to store the product in this
accumulator and we have the number and
we want to return here accumulator x
equals to the number and the initial
value should be what okay
thousand digits oh yeah it's a Const it
doesn't see now this because it's a
constant it's down there all right all
right let's put it up
you
all right good
now Casey the X product arrey arrey
juice accumulator commit x number this
should work we create a new array now
again the last thing wanted to check so
basically now we're going up to M so
this one but after this we don't have
five five numbers so we could go up to n
minus o this
up to am sorry not up to end my bad my
bad we need to go up to thousand digits
not length the length of this and we can
subtract the head so not the last ones
let's see this works like that
all right yes so definitely networks now
let's see for for what we get so he had
that number
now the bad part is that we can't really
really debug this it's the long list so
let's see we have this array we have the
Max product start with zero we return
the max product that's fine
here we're going over all the numbers
sorry we're going over yeah the digits
and we're slicing the digits we need
thank you can see yeah I hope people
enjoy so we're slicing from i to i plus
n plus one so the length plus one
because it doesn't go to the end good
now here something happened
[Music]
we're going to the length up to the
length minus n minus 5 well basically we
want to check the the fort well if we
check the last 5
we want to go up to this number right so
it's minus n this is n plus 1 oh we need
to check this and with the with his
friends so plus 1 ok but we still don't
get a correct number or do we know you
know yet next we have this product which
is a radius let's
and thinking how can we test this
because if well if we
here comes something I counted a lot
product just so we can see we get a lot
of hammers
well I guess
we try deleting these or you know what
let's comment this out and let's write
again just with a couple of number so we
can check what happens all right so we
have one two three four five six numbers
and we want to check let's see the pair
of three now let's let's leave it for so
basically these four or these four or
these four are the largest now we kind
of need to see what we get the product
so consume the lock product and let's
also the product let's also see the
array
okay so we see that we already have some
issue here
we get five numbers and we only need
four
so +5 oh yeah so my bad here we don't
have +1
logic was correct but the implementation
was wrong so if we start here this is I
+ 1 + 5 so 1 2 3 4 5 but then we added
one more yeah so this already goes up to
the number we want plus 1 all right
my bad good so this should work now
hopefully
well yeah let's see so we get these
numbers and we get it the maximum to be
126 and also you can see how nicely we
get all the pairs here if we add in one
more number here like nine we always get
an array of four numbers which is
perfect alright let's come and this out
let's remove this and look at that we
have the number 5832 let's run this and
yeah and we got to 2% awesome now what
could we improve if we could improve
something one thing would be well I
created this function but we kind of
hailer and how are you welcome we kind
of kept well we could do this here right
it's just a function calling reduce so
we can do that there all right but other
than that I don't really see how we
could improve it
the well we're working with this the way
should think about how to improve it is
when you have a loop right you want to
see if you could somehow not have a loop
or have less iterations
but I think for this one should be fine
you wish you could cope with it okay I
think you can't cut yeah so we kinda
need to go over all the numbers I don't
think we can cheat somehow I don't
really think
oh yeah I think this is the proach maybe
someone can find something even better
but I can't for now all right let's run
this and submit and there we go vii
done twelve eight really when did we
start to date all right let's go to the
ninth then all right let's drink some
water
we need to be a bit of a break
good ix problem special Pythagorean
triplet hopefully I pronounced that
right a Pythagorean triplet is a set of
three natural numbers sorry a less than
B less than C for which a squared plus B
squared equals C squared yeah yeah this
is another math heavy problem so for
example 3 squared plus 4 squared is 9
plus 16 which is 25 which is 5 squared
so this is a Pythagorean well 3 4 & 5
it's called the Pythagorean Pythagorean
triplet there exists exactly one
Pythagorean triplets for which a plus B
plus C equals 1000 find the product a B
C such that a plus B plus C equals 10
okay
uh what
we need three numbers which are
Pythagorean triplets well part of my
Tiger paper Pythagorean triple I'm going
to mess this up row saying by Pythagoras
and when we find them we need to check
if there's some equals two
and then we need to multiply them
I'm not sure did I understood this
correctly
[Music]
so there exists exactly one triplet for
which a plus B plus equals a thousand
okay
find the product a B C such that oh yes
so the product a B C this is a product
okay such that a B C equals that
ABC equals 24 the product should be 480
oh okay so ABC
here we have a square B Square C square
oh okay yeah
couple things to check
mmm
here we have a plus B plus C will be
let's see 3 plus 4 plus 5 9 12 okay what
would be 424
now I think the way we could do this is
to I have three loops in mind like two
inner loops one going from for a one for
B 1 for C and then for C going up to a
number yeah Thank You kattiline have a
good day now
yeah I'm not but thanks
let's see so I'm going to write
something just so we have a starting
point for left I not I a equals one a
less then
something ABM what I said eh but I wrote
I ate nah I plus plus all right and here
well let's go for B and C
B and C now B has to we have hit this
condition here so B has to be one bigger
than a at least and see one bigger than
B at least so we can do here B equals a
plus one and C equals B plus one all
right now we need to check if there are
Pythagorean triplets of if is triplet
ABC if it is
we need to check its SAP and if we find
the sum we can return there
[Music]
find the sum to be close to this number
then we can return the product so let's
see if it's a triplet and
a plus B plus C equals M
right
but this year then we want to return a
times B times e okay this is not
some of ABC yeah that's provided add it
there and we don't need this so we kind
of do everything in these slopes
although I don't know if it's the best
way but yeah so we go up to the number
now again we go up to the number but we
probably shouldn't because well the
number in this case will be 24 but we
kind of need the sum to be 24 so it's
obviously that three numbers which are
greater than each other
they can't add up we can't all go to 24
so yeah but that's not just one we can
fix later now let's create this is
triplet functions function is triplet we
get ABC and let's see so we need to
check if a squared plus B squared equals
C squared
the third a squared plus B squared
equals C squared
look
yeah it shouldn't be if it looked not
sure why they said that
we are not reassigning see so yeah
should be good let's see castle that
love this although this is not undefined
okay
so a list and
if is triplet and if the the some damn
otherwise let's retired one here just
okay let's check for 24
what
and compute see out of a and B
what to mean
okay so for 24 we get the number
she's good now for 120
we get this number and 4,000
hello pression welcome welcome to
support a roll
so you saw that it works for 24 and 120
although they say this or this or this
but now for a thousand yeah test timeout
because well
uhh
you can compute the out of a and B
I feel like you have something there so
we don't need to go another loop and I
kind of have an idea of what you're
trying to say let's see so definitely
this doesn't work because we have a loop
of 1000 and 1000 and 1000 so that's a
lot of thousands but as you said
can compare to see out of AMV
yeah yeah yes yes yeah so C will be a
and minus B minus a right that's what
you mean
so then we don't need this look so then
we're pretty fast and look at that that
solved it
thank you aren't I well I couldn't have
done it without you yes so we don't need
to look for see because we can find out
what si si is by doing the subtraction
right because we know a we know B we
know ed yeah thanks that's really good
please stay around I need your help
all right it's pretty good and I think
now they're passing the test Oh such a
good feeling but yeah let's think I
don't like the fact that we're going up
to n right because well definitely don't
need to check for a to B and at anytime
it could go up to at most and - - right
so see could be now no definitely not
but how so if we have a sum of three
numbers b24
what's the lowest take well the highest
a can go it can be something like
yeah I couldn't eat out you gave me this
idea it was very good
so if you have three numbers adding up
to a number
how can we check what's the maximum
value to that so it could be for 24 so
we have ABC equals 24
it could be 23 but then B and C well it
couldn't be 23 or 22 because C B and C
needs to be higher so definitely the sum
couldn't be 24 then it could be half no
way because if it's half then B is
bigger than the half and C is even
bigger so again we don't need to go up
to n if not even up to half of it this
will still work also be doesn't go
doesn't need to go up to half of n again
of the same principle right so have
three numbers there's some is 24 yeah I
think here we already saved a lot of
loops but I still need to see could we
find out how much they can go I think
twenty four three numbers so definitely
well if we divide by three because we
have three numbers then yeah that's
that's an idea so yeah and talking too
much now let's write something so we
have 24 this could be something like
seven plus eight plus nine the most
right because 24 divided 24 divided by
three blah blah blah and here we get
this so a could go up two and divide it
by three minus one
and this could go and divide by three
like that
up to okay so up to
we broke
why this could be a divided by 3 minus 1
K B and C could be at most third part
plus 1
we broke it somewhere let's see for 24
still works yeah for 120 okay so here
doesn't oh this is the correct answer
I taught it's forty nine thousand nine
hundred and twenty
or its dalda the tree yeah I'm kind of
spending a lot of time on this one but I
want to see if we could find the best
approach
it is the square root
I don't follow that buddy don't follow
only have a problem we turn a thousand
which gives us one so it doesn't find a
triplet
so we broke it once we set here divided
by three
trying some random numbers not to say
yeah so apparently it's not divided by
three
well you know what be good
could be pretty big
I made a mistake so this is for a it
could be at most seven but then B could
be something like
square root Oh
and that
or a triplet check right so this is 4a
and 4b we need to see the maximum so we
kinda could do a b1
I equal 1 then be equal to and that
leaves us two Oh No
so B could be
that's Tess so half 11 I think and then
C could be tough right
they need to be they always need to be
bigger than it well see bigger than baby
bigger than a so it could go up to 11
which is half yeah that was my my
mistake
so a can go bigger than seven which is
1/3 well one less than the third and B
can go up with more than half I'll also
have minus one here Anna I think if you
put two here it will it will still work
in this case but might break in other
cases let's see yeah so what I wanted to
do is here is to find to improve this to
make it as fast as possible who knows
maybe there are even better ways to
check it to do it so we are here
undefined
well which is by default so we can even
remove these
all right good let's go to the next one
we spent way more time to this problem
ten summation of primes primes again all
right
the sum of the primes below 10 is 17
find the sum of all the primes below and
okay this doesn't seem that we'll look
at this it is a big number we definitely
need
we need to improve this might be a
timeout if you do the brute-force but
let's start with the brute force so
again we need to have a function which
will check if it's Prime let me write it
down fast so let
I beat to I less than equal a less than
man that square root of n we did this in
the previous the previous child so I'm
not going over it again well I guess he
couldn't we could thread yeah we could
test here and module still equals to
zero then third false and here we could
the three and plus equals 2 so we
improve it even more if and modulus I is
0 then we won't return false let me push
this also like this just to make it
pretty and otherwise if you don't have
these we have a prime number so to get
so we have a prime checker in to do to
do okay yeah this looks good now
wait a second there we go
it should go for - okay good and now
let's go
overall the numbers up to
and
and find the primes and then add them up
so cost primes will be well too and here
let's have let current or what number be
three while number is less than and we
want number plus plus and here we want
to check if is prime number then want to
add it in the primes ray so this way we
add all the primes let's see
Prime's here
council that love here and let sees a
smaller number get so yeah
below 17 we have taste so find the sum
of all the primes below n okay so not
inclusive yeah yeah and that we kind of
need to add to add them up so we could
use videos accumulator number
accumulator plus equals number started
zero and Paula ring not voila
does it work why is that
let's check for ten you get twenty six
which is not good let's see what we have
in the primes two three five
seven and nine oopsie
why do we have nine as a prime
whoops up to so I less than equals to
square root of n up well inclusive all
right they should fix it so excited yeah
so we get 17 good
fingers crossed yeah it works okay so we
have a function we check the primes then
we get all the price we put it in a
primes array
or you know what we can even don't do
this and just have a total total b2 and
every time we find we just do a total
plus equals number why do we do a reduce
here not sure all right
nom todo
total is read-only yeah obviously we
need something like this alright so yeah
is there a better way to test this we
kinda did optimization here so we don't
go up to the number if it would go up to
the number let's see what would happen
here
so we go up
it's not even check for two so I just
want to show you that the brute force
might not work so we go over all the
numbers right
if anarchy falls first good so let's see
yeah it doesn't work because I did
something
okay yeah so we need to check for 2.41
so yeah this is the brute force
well the longest and you can see that it
will timeout
I think yeah so this is why we need to
improve it by adding these small tricks
all right
hope that made sense so here basically
we would go up to a number like what's
here to Melia
[Music]
but by doing this first we remove half
of the checks by doing plus equals two
right second we move
I'm not sure what's the square root of
two million but well let's check console
Dethklok man that square root of
million
yeah so we don't go up to two million we
go up to four thousand so that's a lot
of millions worth of loops right so you
can see how fast it is now is it two
million
yeah hit it oh okay so I I added here 20
million so it goes only up to 1414 and
also it skips every other number so it
kinda does only 700 loops and the brute
force did 2 million so you can see how's
that good
also you can could get this question in
an interview so it's good to know
something like this I think all right
let's run this and go to the next one
Thank You Laurent please be please stick
around oh boy
now this will be complicated
should we do this or go take a nap
all right largest product in a great
okay we did something similar but it
wasn't in a grade it was in a row so
let's see in a 20 by 20 grid below four
numbers along the diagonal diagonal line
have been marked in red why the product
of this number is big number what is the
greatest product of for adjacent numbers
in the same direction
up-down left-right or diagonally in a
given array
I don't know all right so now this is
interesting
you
[Music]
okay I see here we have an array of
arrays
yeah be pretty pretty tricky so we kind
of let's go back to the challenge
resolved
there was this
[Music]
largest product in a series this one
here we only had to go one way but in
this we need to go in a lot of ways so
we need to go to the right
to the left up down and diagonally this
is fun yeah to watch it's very fun to
watch
okay so we have an array of arrays which
gets the inner race gets the rose okay
we could
you
let's think good start by going like
this and well do the same thing we did
here
do we have no we don't have the code
anymore oops we could have used that so
we could go line by line and check what
we did previously right that will be
going to the right and laugh right
because well it's the same thing up and
down is the same thing that's one
approach
well one we kind of need to do three
things to the right down and diagonal
to the right and to the left yeah that's
three
this will probably take up the remaining
time all right so first we go like this
then we go like this and then we need to
go like this and well when we're here we
need to go like this and check all of
them
and store the biggest product
okay let's stop complaining and start
doing something good too bad I didn't
save that I'm not sure why why why I
didn't save it we could have used that
so we need to think basically where we
have a look that I call zero I less than
a Raider flanked I plus plus this will
go
this will go on a collar and then left I
J equals zero J less than or a that
length J + + this will go from left to
right right
alright yeah so here we can go to right
by checking what we had
wait what's the four numbers okay so the
number left lengths or I don't know and
be for no man and don't like him
we need to sew the length to to check
it's a bit too long but that's what we
need to do so here if you check to the
right well
you
okay so
we can check like with it right so we
get an array which will be but we have
array already here so
is the great Catholic a KKK KKK let's
write this somewhere else oh great we
have Greek here
metrics yeah that sounds better
so have them metrics that's her that's
the right thing but alright and here we
need a sub array which will be by the
way here we need to go metrics of I not
like because it's the inner ray the sub
sub array here will be matrix of I
that's slice from J up to J plus lengths
to check yeah so this is what we did
previously and here well let's start up
let max product be 0 and here we need to
do if cost product will be sub array
that reduce accumulator number
accumulator x equals number and we start
with one and if product is greater than
max product then max product will be
product right we solved one to the right
which will basically head in the
previous challenge this is why I went a
bit a bit faster over it good but now we
need to go down so how we did that two
down let's have another
Oh
[Music]
now the only issue here is that we're
not if you remember in the previous one
in the problem aid we kind of go we went
up to this number and we checked to the
last four but now we go up to this
number which won't have so the slice
will only return this
but then the product will be it will be
just this number so it shouldn't worry
us but if we go like this if we end up
here
well sorry here we need to check one two
and nothing so that could be let's see
could you see that yeah okay so yeah
here we don't have anything
uh and we need to check for that and
then we have two diagonals which will be
okay
good so two down two down well
let's do the brute force and then we can
see so basically when we're here we need
this this and this oops
this this and this when we're here we
need D this this and this and so on and
so forth so let's write this right for a
okay and right product right product and
we do this for the right and then to
down
we need a down array which will be an
array with metrics of
ethics of I and J this will be the
current title so this one now we need
this one which is I plus 1 and J so
matrix of I plus 1 and J then matrix of
well let me put this here so see we go
down on the row the reason why I'm doing
everything here is because I don't want
to go multiple times over the entire
grade ok I plus 2 and J and matrix well
do you know what it's not that hard
actually it's just what type I was
worried for nothing so yeah now we have
two down array but this while this won't
exist
well it it could not exist so I applaud
if we're here I plus two is nothing so
we don't have a jailer so we kind of
need to check for death too so if we
have matrix of I plus one
we want to get that
do we have it or it could be zero
okay so how do we check he's different
than undefined we get that and otherwise
we get well what write the number
multiple well in the product if you have
one and multiply with anything it will
be still the same number all right so I
think this is what we need to do for all
of this and if you don't have it we just
say one
okay Kanna tree property sale of
undefined
why so if Matty's side oh sorry to entry
that could get so yeah now we kind of
checked for those test cases and yeah
let's do
here can strike product
I kind of want to move this in a
separate functional so down product will
be down array and all that so whoops
you could create a downer with a loop
four times incrementing the row I'd
check yeah but that's another loop so I
kind of did it manually here all right
let me write a function get product and
this will get an array and we're going
to do this thing here
we third array reduce blah blah blah all
that so now we get the product of down
array and here we get the product of
right array loops
look see
get product of right all right
okay so now we're left to check for
diagonal 1 and diagonal too so it's just
a lot of type typing to do and more than
its art so diagonal to check
direct check
the bottom that's right if to the down
is something check diagonal one and
check diagonal two
let's think so we need to go from this
and go like this and so on and so forth
we always need to check if we get to the
indexes
[Music]
yeah
okay so here we have kind of a bit of a
problem
Oh No yeah it should be good so we go
like this from top to bottom right and
then from top to bottom left from
diagonal - I was thinking that when
we're here we need to check this - but
we already have it if we go down that
way let's see so here we need to curl
down and we get here we don't need to go
all right so yeah
you
today
it's something like this here and here
this will be diagonal one array this
will be diagonal one product this will
be diagonal one ray this will be product
and product so many copy and pasting can
don't truly
yeah all right
we have actually you know what let me
delete this and I'm going to copy this
and change it once to tools too
to
- - all right good now what's that when
we are here this element is I plus 1 J
plus 1 right so I plus 1 J plus 1
we also need to check if we have that
right because when we are here we don't
have I plus one there now the second one
is I plus 1 J plus 2 I plus 1 J plus 3
now the issue is that we might not have
this
and then we get undefined
[Music]
I don't really want to do another
ternary operator
although yeah this won't look very good
but let me do this just for now so we're
going to check if this a constant find
well not equal it's different than
undefined if it does then while we're
going to add it otherwise we add one
so we're checking there
we're checking the dead
happened
and expected comma
okay so this one No
oh yeah another comma here yeah this is
a bit silly so we're checking if we have
the first we have the I here if we don't
have it then we want to put an one in
the array then we're checking if we have
this if you don't have it we put a none
one in your a and if we have them both
then we put that number
uhh
yeah I'm going to think about a way to
improve this so this could kind of work
let me put it two more times
and we're going to change you could go
only with the metrics length minus 4 for
ing
yeah but I still need to check hey sorry
I don't get it that well now so let me
do that brute force so we're going to
set that with tree and this weed well
that with two and this with three KKK so
yeah that's not good carry property
three of undefined
you
oh okay I see
oh no it should be good so if this is
undefined it goes here
check this one
if this is not on the final it goes here
otherwise one one so why we get three is
undefined
probably a messed up something
yes this will be diagonal one and the
agonal two will be let's let them put it
here kind of silly but yeah so we're
here we want to go this way so minus 1
minus 1 minus 2 minus 2 minus 2 minus 3
all the pluses here all day
all the pluses here will be minuses
cannot treat property - still undefined
oops
why do I get on the fan I don't see it
and you're here well with this Everett
well everything works we should have the
max product here but it doesn't also
at 20 by 20 okay so it's square square
grid
you
canary property - so here doesn't look
right
oh okay I see so I forgot to change the
first part here the first check
okay so I think we have it now although
these checks of looking awful but let's
where it is
let's cancel the plug this
we don't get a good number there is no
way oh we could test on the test
great although yeah again
right so what's happening there
I'm going to rewrite the test grade
just so that's just we can test so we're
going to have nine nine nine one one one
copy dates three times it will have 99
it will have nine and nine so we only
have nine and I don't diagonals
other than that we'll have one of
everywhere and we should get oh sorry
so let's put two instead
at 16 which works what happens if we add
one more
we should still get 16 okay
yeah we should get a
a times 324 we get 24 so
then what's wrong what about if we got
the other diagonal
oops one one oh boy this is so badly
formatted don't like but nevertheless
two two two two
okay so you can see now that it doesn't
all let me format this because I don't
like it yeah so it doesn't pick up this
yet we know where is the issue he is
here
oh yeah my bad so it goes - one - one -
it goes up top up top yeah the pop up
and left and we don't want that we want
down and left so down plus one down
and well this plus one again probably
you're yelling at your screens now but
oh well see this is what why it's good
to debug and write this dumbest code
example alright look at this so
basically if you're looking at this
number we went this way so we went from
five to forty seven thirty one and zero
and we needed to go from five to sixty
nine ninety nine sixty two
okay that sound let's see test
okay so I think that doesn't work
because I change it change the test grid
yeah bro
yeah look at that oh boy this was a
tough one
well tough because we had to write a lot
of code
do I want to improve this yeah I guess I
could remove the space here but that's
all
banking
we have a lot of kind of copy and
pasting and changing the values and I
this check is you know not very very
clear
[Music]
one thing it could do
yeah I have an idea let's try that so
instead of doing the ternary operator we
could do and end here so it's going to
check the sec well we need that instead
of this actually and we're going to do
the shirt secret method and we could
avoid no death so if this is
[Music]
go here if it is false it will put false
inside array that's what we want to
avoid now well we need to check here
when you do the product but yeah that's
that's another thing we'll need to worry
about now the good thing with this
approach is that
to fight a lot but let's see here
instead of doing this third triple
ternary we could do matrix I plus one
and matrix I plus 1 and J plus 1
again so different then
don't think why I'm checking
could be couldn't be zero so it'll be
just undefined so let's try this so it's
going to check for this if it's an array
it will be true
if it's not well told be undefined if
it's undefined it will be false so it
will well beyond the finally side array
which is good so I think now we could do
this everywhere but just for simplicity
sake let's comment it out and
do the simple version first here so plus
two plus three and this was plus wait
wait we're plus two plus three plus two
plus three and we get the same number
whoa
okay okay I think I know why so our
product method here so this number could
be let
I can only want to show you one so how
can they do that
so if we do here console that log array
hopefully don't break my yeah won't
break my
[Music]
my browser but you can see that
sometimes we get undefined
and apparently two x undefined it will
probably convert this to 0 and that's
good we get is the total of 0 let me
check with clay here so if we get
console that flog 2 times undefined
should be easier not a number
all right
not a number but then we do this
diagonal to which is a number is it
greater I think that's why so we need
did she see why why Java scripts the way
it does so we need to check if 3 is
greater than this and it's false
so it's not greater so it won't add it
all right works for me
although the best thing to do would be
a to check if this number is actually is
not a number and convert it to to a
number or up to zero if it's undefined
but the trick works so let's not worry
about that now
good so the last thing we'll do here
I'm going to copy this again if I mess
it up just to have a backup and we need
to do this at
yeah look at how much code was safe with
that pretty crazy face the scene plus 2
Plus 3 plus 2 plus 3 minus 2 minus 3 all
right
yeah
remove the test grade here use this get
eventually that number okay and I'm of
taste so yeah this looks much much
cleaner now
I like it
goody-goody how we say it in our stream
yeah let's submit and it works now if
the good thing is that we only go over
the matrix once and we check everything
aside here the only thing we could kind
of well we could think of let's see what
Lauren says so I was thinking if you
look at the number 40 in the bottom
right
or tin the button okay this one
then you see you do not need to go
further than I equals 16
and J equals 16
oh yeah you're right so we could do I
think - length - check
though they're not really know because
we need to go here and check this
diagonal so we kind of need to go up
until here
hey Quincy I'm glad you're still around
yeah
goody-goody yeah you wrote it wrong
though it's goody-goody yeah that's our
saying okay so
we can
to go up to 36 well we don't need yeah
we don't need to go on this road though
so that could be that could save us a
couple of check so length to check right
No
like to check plus one yeah
so yeah you were right yeah you're right
torrid yeah nice clever clever guy I
like I like I like the way you're
thinking get so yeah we could just go up
to this row because it will go
oh but you know what
then it won't check to the right here
and it
now
what if the number is on this row
we won't get it
hmm
so yeah you know what let's leave it
like this we kind of need to check even
this one right now
and that one and yeah this one here is
diagonal so we need to go to this number
we need to go to this number
yeah so this isn't
we can't really cheat so we do that and
we're using the undefined in JavaScript
just to play around it can i if I do
come and save yeah look at that it
sailed into browser local storage good
if we need it all right let's see what's
the next one if it is too hard well if
it's more complicated than
oh well I almost didn't submit all right
every direction has a prefer to limit
not sure what to mean by that
sorry I am I might just be tired okay
let's see what's this about and it fits
till I guess we could try it highly
divisible triangular number
again the sequence of triangle numbers
is generated by adding the natural
numbers so the seventh triangle number
will be one plus two plus blah blah blah
the first 10 terms will be 1 3 6 10 15
21 and so on let us list the factors of
the first seven triangles triangle
number sorry ok we can see the 28th is
the first triangle number to have over
five divisors
what is the value of the first triangle
number to have over ten divisors
yeah
you know what let's let's leave this for
the next week Street I think I will have
a fresh mind yes so basically we need to
get all these numbers
and then check the divisors
[Music]
once the first value was developed first
triangle number two have over nd
resource
yeah
and you know what let's they know that
kind of dictate now okay so we're going
to loop over all the numbers eyes ear oh
I is 1 I less than what we don't know so
we need the for a while loop while
while to don't like that it will
complain but while too
we need to let is one we get here
need to do them all in one go yeah I
know but at least do as many as we can
so we improve this while we get I plus
one at the end
and here while we need to check cast
length the d'azyr's
or I know the Visser's baby's arse
hmm
you
again reserves
prime numbers and all that
they'll be an array and we need to check
here if TVs source dot length so let's
see what is the value of the first
triangle number to have over and the
whizzers so if it's greater than n we
want to return the number which we don't
have now so
to get the number constant number I
think this will be trying little number
triangle number would be get
get get get get
get triangle value and we're going to
paste in I this is the number right
okay and let's write that function get
triangle value I didn't wrote it right
here four in number and here we need to
go up to that number can add all the
numbers so one way we could cheat kind
of well let's do a for loop let's sum
equals zero for let I equals 1 I less
than equals to number I plus plus sound
plus equals I and retired sup alright so
we get we kind of get these numbers
right so for 1 we have 1 foot the number
2 we have a triangle number of 3 1 plus
2 4 6 we have 1 plus 2 Plus 3 I kind of
see a pattern here
over way we don't need to do this but
well we'll get that in a moment because
we basically have the sum already we
just need to add a number than another
number so we don't need to do this loop
over and over all right so we get that
triangle number and then we need to get
deep fizzers let me put this here and
write the function get the deserts of
triangle number function get the V
source do yeah one cut off number and
here
yeah I wanted to read this you know me
so well
so we need constant divisors array we
want to look loop over all of them I
Swan I less than equal to man that
square root of number I
I plus plus
now I kind of see something we could
improve here nevertheless
oh we need to go up to the number or we
could just add it yeah oh okay so no
square root
my let's go up to the number and because
basically number here when you check if
number modulus
I is zero right if it is then resource
push you don't deal with primes
I had Prime's might push PI and here we
want to return the divisors
goody goody
want to check for five though good and
triangle number I want to cancel the
flock let's see what we get
well we got it look at that
well it work for all of them turned out
probably but we have a we have an ace we
can use have an ace in our sleeves not
sure if that's used in English but we
know meaning we have that thing good so
the issue we well one thing
[Music]
not Kay so I kind of see a pattern here
the girls up to the number the half of
it
so up to half of the number this is one
improvement
oh yeah so we kind of have one by
default we need to hear
and the bazaars that push we need to
pull the number at the end because we're
going captain up the half so then we
don't have the number itself
although if we have one with the only
one one that's a special case so if
number is one return
but an array of one this is special case
for one
all right so then we Canada taste which
is good
we saved half of the iterations although
I think it still turned out because not
we don't have a problem here that we
don't have a big problem here we have a
problem here
okay so the triangle number
uhh
[Music]
triangle number they're recreating
always the Sun but we don't have to the
triangle number should be here I
now let's make it zero and here we're
going to the triangle number will be
plus equals I
okay so not cost so here we're just
adding and we don't need this function
because well by default we have zero
then it goes here it will be 1 because
well for one we have one but when we
have two the number two we have one
already and we add two when I have 3 we
have 1 plus 2 which is 3 and we're three
so that's good
increment well no comment
I don't have a mind of a comment I plus
plus
I guess we could do at first was here
yeah well let's leave it like this just
to make it be better
okay so yeah this is it
don't like this while through a loop but
how many times do we need to loop
we could move these dividers outside
let's do that constantly deserts will be
rent array and we're going to check this
well the visitors that length is less
than or equal to n we're going to do
this now we save a couple of wealth it
basically to loop the same amount of
times but at least we don't have a while
true and here well we could pre read you
read only okay left yeah
although I kind of like the wild through
there but ya know it's not the best
sometimes push number
something like let's see that number or
wait
the Wizards that
got a method
concat number yes and they'll do the
push there so we start with one
oh you know what let's do something else
here it we're going to do the check here
if number is one we want to return the
whizzers
nukkie otherwise we're going to do this
yet let's it still works
timed out well I didn't check
while - well true - we had it working
right did I broke break something
what happened
you
I totally forgot if I had it working or
not
you
and cats shouldn't matter that much
though
let's see 23 works 167 potentially fatal
OOP undefined
okay not good so we still
do you remember if we had it working I
can't forget
and yeah probably not so we still have
an infinite well a timeout
we too
[Music]
you
the only thing we could improve is here
this loop
we get it deserves
the length returned a triangle
Oh
you
is there a way to get the Visser's by
not doing a loop
can we improve the loop
you
yeah fine so it is working but it stand
out so it's not fast enough
you
ah
yeah we kind of don't need
need a length of the divisors
get Wizards liked
so we don't store it in an array you
just get linked
and here we check if the length is
greater than and here the length that
length be zero
well true let's make it well to again so
while two we check the length and here
instead of doing this we're going to
return the d'azyr's what that length
last one well
again we don't need to push the array
okay so if number is one we want to
return one a else let's
first length oldest one and here we just
increase the length length plus plus so
I think all these pushing and getting
from the Ray was hurting us get a
visitor's light so this is a way with a
length is read only Kiki what
undefined so get visuals length they
have triangle number we go over the
numbers if it's divisible then we
improve the length and really turn
seems legit
and well we don't need a special case I
think length will be one and here
yeah it won't go inside the loop now
let's check for five again
thirty-six okay so something is not
working right
oh I see we forgot here if you remember
we added the divisions pause we added
the last number because we go up to the
half of it so we need to do the length
plus one all right but then here blank
should be zero
should be zero and I should be
one and should be yeah yeah okay good so
length zero and our stuff we start with
2 pi 1 and then we add one at the end
there is something about the divisors
what
let's see now we changed to an array
well from an array so we're not working
with an array but still it might
probably too much
well we have the right answer there do
we have 4:23 we have do we have for 167
we have undefined
because it's an infinite loop and a well
it will just break out of it so I think
we need a way to get and all the
divisors of a number so go bail please
help us get all the visas over number
let's see do we have some kind of
formula wicked years
says meantime
just say formula
if it's a loop to adorn you're not
interested if I look at 28 let's see
what what Lawrence's if you look at 28 I
see the first two divisions are
important one two and four dollars
calculated by yeah but what about
Oh
[Music]
the next one which will be a 36
but what's 36 divisors 36 will be one
two three four six
10 now at 12
right these should be right revisers
five is not seven eight is not oh nine
we have nine ninety five by four twelve
eighteen
they're always couples
okay I see what you mean here we have
two four six eight but
how do we know
what's the let's see let's go to 45 we
have 1 3 5
fifteen
and for five I miss something right
No
you say and / I
my eyes hurt wait wait so 40-45 here
1:20 approximately 2.14
and / hi
okay my head hurts now
techno so yeah you see here we don't
have like you said pairs
right
we have nine so we have pairs and / I
and which will be 40 now
but what's the N
we received you say
you
Oh
so here if I is a divisor
ad
/
yeah oh I think I see what you mean so
here we don't need to get so
like only over three
so the square root was the square root
of yeah we get seven so I see if we have
one we have n divided by 128 if we have
to we have n divided 14 if we have four
we have n divided seven but what's the
condition we go up to what square root
the square root of twenty twelve the
square root of ten eight mad at square
root 20
fine whoa yay we candidate
so here we can go
up - let's check that square root of
number and we can do plus equals two
so here what was the function this and
we need to pass in what five
okay so it kind of works and now we're
dropping a lot
is is very nice why did they think that
the square root of 28 is 9
it's five so all it goes up to half of
them square root of 21 is
I'll get this four in a bit yeah
so I think this solves it
yeah now you can't say now that I
couldn't done this without you well I
would have done well yeah I wouldn't
want to look over some code so
I didn't want to cheat
/ co' they wanted to cheat looking over
math but yeah that's a very good point
we dropped from going up to the half of
the number up to the square root which
is huge
and yeah we kind of need to do the same
thing but here we just have to not sure
why we need to do this but oh well yeah
let's let's run this see it works submit
and they done with it
if numbers modules is zero and I am the
number yeah we don't have the divisions
or error anymore we change it to so we
wanted to do something you we lost
everything
yeah Freaker camp you should store my
solution oh wait maybe I go here
portfolio
uhh
yes yeah oops
[Laughter]
yeah we don't have it anymore
well yeah it was pretty fun
although hard sometimes
all right thank y'all for watching this
or listening I really hope you enjoyed
it if you enjoyed it give this video a
like and don't forget we're doing life
every Wednesday so come back in next
Wednesday
where we're going to attempt to do more
of this and when we're going to get
stuck sometimes which hopefully it won't
happen we want to get to 100 but I
honestly don't think I can do it up to
100 maybe only with your help
but yeah come back in every Wednesday
and we're going to continue also let's
see there is a button saying don't blow
to run the tests
wait to work
well
you
matt serwe to me all right so the
download button
yeah I don't see all right okay
thanks all for watching if you want to
check out my channel free free I have a
link in the description of this video we
are doing all kind of stuff they're
coding JavaScript CSS react and all that
and yeah I'll see you next week here on
the freakin camp YouTube channel where
we're going to continue this series I
have a great great day and I'll see you
next time bye